perspective is a powerful tool for
storytelling in film and TV you can
control perspective with the writing
through what stories you choose to focus
on and how you tell them you can control
it with the cinematography and how you
frame an event visually and you can
control it in the Edit with where you
place the focus of the scene one of the
things that makes the Chernobyl
miniseries so powerful is its use of
perspective let's look at how the
creators of Chernobyl from the writers
to the editors shaped the perspective of
each episode scene and the show as a
whole and how that impacts the story
this video is brought to you by movie
what is perspective in film and TV I'm
not talking about point of view shots
where we see what the character sees
though that is one tool that helps
establish the perspective of a scene
perspective is the vantage point from
which the audience experiences the scene
emotionally and dramatically I'll show
some of the tools Chernobyl uses to
establish its perspective as we go along
[Music]
Chernobyl chooses a more subjective
approach to telling its story using the
perspective of individuals in a lot of
scenes subjective here doesn't mean less
factual just that the goal is to tell
the story as those characters
experienced it instead of trying to give
the clearest possible account the
account is more personal meant to
emotionally convey the event as it was
experienced a perfect example of this is
episode 4 the Chernobyl area cleanup was
a massive project spanning years and
involving thousands of people but in
order to tell this story the series
chooses to mostly focus on one group of
three men performing one job and then
within that group the experience of one
young man
it's extremely difficult to make a story
about many people emotionally impactful
psychologically humans are more likely
to empathize with individuals than with
groups so focusing the story on an
individual allows for maximum emotional
impact all you need then is a few visual
clues to show the audience that the
experience of this one individual can be
multiplied by thousands in taking a more
subjective perspective like this you'll
sacrifice some information in the show
we don't learn many details about all
the other jobs that were being done but
it allows us to be more emotionally
invested in the characters the show does
focus on I thought well that's it about
you you put a bullet in someone you're
not you anymore you'll never be you
again but then you wake up the next
morning and you're still you it's not
just important to choose between
subjective and objective perspectives
for your story or scene if you choose a
more subjective perspective whose
perspective you choose for each scene is
incredibly important throughout the
first episode the perspective shifts in
each scene usually to the person in that
scene that is encountering the disaster
for the first time we see the disaster
first from the perspective of the plant
workers as they deal with the initial
fallout from the political characters
perspective as they learn about the
disaster as the firefighters arrive
on-site the show shifts to the
perspective of an individual firefighter
as he's awoken and arrives at the
disaster but when the firefighters are
taken to the hospital we see that scene
from the perspective of a single nurse
being awoken and seeing the effects of
the disaster for the first time this
puts us in the perspective of each
character at the moment of maximum
surprise it's part of what gives the
first episode such a sustained feeling
of tension
while the perspective of each scene
varies the primary perspective of the
story as a whole is Lagasse loves while
many scenes are not from his perspective
most of the scenes he's in are framed in
his perspective the show establishes
this by beginning with his suicide and
him recording himself telling the story
what does that mean
no one knows doesn't matter
showing us this event largely through
the eyes of someone who eventually
killed himself because of it sets the
tone throughout the show when we see his
reactions to everything that is
happening we know what it's leading
towards the show is in effect increasing
suspense by showing a reaction and then
showing what caused that reaction this
is a technique the show will use again
to dramatize exposition like this
[Music]
fireman was severely burned on his hand
by a trunk of smooth black mineral on
the ground outside the reactor building
smooth Blackmun of graphite there's
there's graphite on the ground this
exposition is dramatically powerful
because we saw the gaseous reaction to
it just a few minutes earlier
[Music]
professor lacrosse off you can also use
perspective to make the revelation of
information feel more meaningful you do
this by showing it to the audience from
the perspective of the person that the
information would be most meaningful to
if you want to dramatize the
firefighters medical situation construct
those scenes from the perspective of one
of the firefighters wives trying to get
to her husband and seeing him
deteriorate
being here if you want to show how far
spread the disaster is show this
information being discovered by someone
who is far away and who understands the
implications of the disaster and how far
it's reaching I've never wronged him
Malik no I would have gone off before
it's coming from outside perspective is
established in the writing but the
entire production team must work
together to create those perspectives
and actually sell the effect to the
audience let's go back to the
firefighter and his wife in the scene
where she and the audience sees his
condition for the first time we do see
him but notice how most of what the
camera focuses on is her face the shot
is an example of using cinematography to
establish perspective if you pay
attention to the cinematography of the
show especially in the first episode
you'll notice how much time is spent on
close-up shots of characters reacting to
things a shot like this of the
firefighter reacting to his comrades
burn is dramatically just as important
as actually showing the burn in some
ways it's more important than actually
seeing what's going on and throughout
episode one we hardly see the details of
the actual disaster this plays an
important role in keeping us in these
characters perspectives the characters
cannot see clearly everything that's
happening so we the audience will not
see an objective view of what's
happening that they do not have access
the shot used to establish the Chernobyl
area before the explosion at the
beginning of the show is not a nice wide
shot of the power plant the focus of the
show it's some apartment buildings in
Pripyat we focus on a character and
experience the explosion from her
perspective as she would have in the
control room
slow-motion sound design and tight
constricting cinematography keep us
focused on the operators and their
emotional state and reaction a wide
steady calm objective camera would pull
us away from the emotional state of the
characters and out of their perspective
it's not literally seeing what the
characters see that puts us in their
perspective when we can see their faces
and reactions and connect with their
emotions when the camera feels like it's
in the room with them we're experiencing
the scene from their perspective in a
scene like this when we see a shot of
legis off by himself in the frame boxed
in and framed by bodies around him were
in his perspective if the
cinematographer had wanted to stay in a
more objective perspective they could
have shown a wider shot more clearly
displaying him with the characters
around him this personal individual
perspective is consistently maintained
throughout most of the first episode
only rarely and quite far into the
episode do we get occasional slow steady
wide shots revealing more of the
disaster itself and we only see these
types of shots as characters themselves
gain these perspectives an explosion
disaster or monster by itself is not
very scary it's relative to characters
we can sympathize with that these things
become terrifying
[Music]
look at this scene from Deepwater
Horizon a film that dramatizes another
real disaster we see certain moments
from the perspective of the characters
but these are intercut with very
objective shots of the mechanics of the
explosion the audience is always aware
in extreme detail of what's happening
even when the characters don't know
what's going on it makes for a flashy ER
scene than we see in Chernobyl but it
removes much of the suspense in favor of
showcasing the explosion in as graphic
detail as possible and it confuses and
models the perspective of the scene and
that's often the failing of many films
it's it's not that they choose the wrong
perspective it's that they fail to use
it as a tool for their benefit and just
somewhat arbitrarily seem to use
whatever perspective is convenient take
the helicopter crash as an example many
shows or films wouldn't be able to
resist the maximal action and drama of
seeing the crash from inside the
helicopter with the pilots yelling as it
falls to the ground
Chernobyl instead only lets us see it
from a distance from the perspective of
those watching it's maybe not as
exciting but excitement isn't the goal
here instead we see and feel the
crushing hopelessness and despair it's
not that Chernobyl is good because it
uses a subjective perspective it's that
it knows when and how to use perspective
effectively the show does use a more
objective perspective in the last
episode we do eventually see the gory
details of the explosion compare how
steady objective and wide the angles are
and how much more clear the geography of
the control room is in these flashbacks
from episode 5 compared to the scenes in
the control room in episode 1 a
different perspective is used because
the intent for the scene is different we
see these flashbacks intercut with the
account of what happened at the trial by
now the characters are more objectively
aware of what really happened and so we
get to see the event in a more objective
light by keeping the cinematography more
subjective and restricting the use of
objective views it also allows the show
to use these objective shots for maximum
impact the score plays a big role here
helping to give these slow creeping
shots a feeling of doom and dread and by
using the same style you use for a shot
this on a shot like this it helps the
audience infer the danger of this pile
of clothing and the show doesn't have to
explain with exposition how radioactive
it is editing also plays an important
role in constructing perspective and you
can see good examples of this throughout
Chernobyl small things like intercutting
a shot of the firefighters of life with
a close-up of his face as he approaches
the reactor he'll place us in his mental
perspective we know he's thinking of her
in this scene we see the meeting from
Lagasse's perspective this is
established largely by leaving the
camera on him in the Edit even while
other people are talking military and
civilian patrols have secured the region
we see his reactions and hold on closer
angles of him instead of showing the
room as a whole another way perspective
is established through editing is by
staying with characters leading up to or
during a significant action establishing
a scene by showing the characters
walking to the location might seem
unnecessary but it helps place the
audience in those characters perspective
for the coming scene for example in this
scene we are mostly analogue Assad's
perspective because we are with him as
he approaches the cell if the editor had
chosen to start the scene inside the
cell and shown from inside ligase
entering we would have felt more like
the scene was from Alana's perspective
in this scene we stay with ligase while
they wait for a reconnaissance team to
return he's back the show could have
stayed with the team as they measured
the radiation levels but staying in
legolas perspective as he and therefore
we the audience wait to find out
increases suspense
it's not three long again it's 15,000
perspective is an incredibly powerful
tool one that Chernobyl uses well this
kind of subjective perspective is not
always the right choice for a story more
objective cinematography writing and
editing can also be used for powerful
effect but I think Chernobyl made the
right choice here to maximize the
dramatic impact of a story many of us
already know some details about
Chernobyl is one of the most effective
shows or films I've seen and conveying a
sense of despair and doom its use of
perspective to place us right alongside
the characters as they feel those things
is an important part of its success
thanks to movie for sponsoring this
video movie is an online cinema
streaming and download platform that
focuses on a hand curated library of 30
films at a time every day they add a new
film that you have 30 days to watch I
often find interesting uses of
subjective and objective perspective in
indie international and art films and
these aren't exactly the type of movies
that you'll get access to with movie
movie doesn't just give you access to
these films it's a great way to discover
new things to watch so if you're looking
to find some interesting things and
expand your film palate I recommend
giving Mubi a try you can try it for
free for 30 days at MU be calm slash
Thomas flight go to MU be calm slash
Thomas flight and give it a try today
thanks everyone for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video I want to give a
special thank you to my patreon
supporters go to patreon.com/scishow
miss flight to find out how you can get
access to my patreon podcasts merch and
extra bonus videos